all right let's jump into this first
story we've got this from the wall
street journal twitter's x security head
files whistleblower complaint on spam
and privacy issues former executive
peter zatko makes sweeping claims about
the social network platform
the complaint which is submitted to the
securities and exchange commission last
month and became public tuesday was made
by peter zatko also known as mud she's a
hacker who was uh fired earlier this
year mr zeko's submission says he had
that he uncovered extreme egregious
deficiencies by twitter in every area of
his mandate including privacy digital
and physical security platform integrity
and content moderation i'm going to jump
over to our good friend elon musk
as many of you know he's suing twitter
because he says they didn't disclose
information on bots he's he's subpoenaed
jack dorsey the former cn uh ceo
and he tweeted this give a little
whistle and it's a chimney cricket and
then underneath it he says so spam
prevalence was shared with the board but
the board chose not to disclose that to
the public
the washington post reported four people
familiar with the company's process for
spam detection who like others spoke on
the condition of anonymity to describe
sensitive internal matters told the post
that the company keeps several internal
tallies of spam and bots known as
prevalence
across the service beyond the number
supplied to wall street the post also
obtained an eternal document which was
redacted to hide the numbers showing
that spam prevalence was a number shared
with the board the document was supplied
to the board at the meetings echo
attended according to two of the people
but not to wall street so does that
include the shareholders how is this
going to work the big revelation here is
that this dude
said he believes
foreign intelligence service
agents or individuals could be at
twitter and they're not doing anything
about it that to me is probably the
biggest red flag and this probably why
in my opinion they freaked out when elon
musk was planning to buy it then some
weird algorithmic thing happened with
the right gaining tons of followers the
left losing tons of followers
then elon musk said i want the data on
bots and they didn't give it to him now
we're learning they didn't give it to
him that they had a number that was
shared with the board well actually i
shouldn't say that
maybe elon musk was given access to this
but because of the nda he wasn't allowed
to talk about it i don't know either way
it sounds like this is going to help him
win
uh which is kind of bad news because
elon winning means he doesn't buy
twitter but i don't know what do you
guys think about this uh foreign
intelligence thing i think that's the
big takeaway huh i'm i'm one of the
biggest elon musk fans and i don't
really care uh if that gets me in
trouble these days you're talking about
a modern-day ironman i was in ukraine
not that long ago this guy's giving away
some communication devices that totally
change and altered the way that that
country stayed uh independent you know
there's a guy who it seems like is
putting his money where his passion is
you know he puts his he puts everything
out there and and i was very excited to
have maybe one platform i could put my
money towards that actually cared about
pushing out the truth cared about
putting
every person's
perspective out there and not moderating
not censoring not blocking people's
opinions i've been on social
for 10 plus years starting my company
off facebook and instagram advertising
in november of this last year right
before black friday cyber monday
facebook given its infinite wisdom
decided that i needed to be banned my
company to be banned so i had well i
mean look at that hat dude absolutely
that's a dangerous hat and actually you
know when we broke down the violations
right you know they couldn't really get
me on anything except for my brother
posted six years ago about a partnership
we had with jeep they said that was
violating intellectual property of jeep
i mean jeep didn't complain because i
actually had paperwork and i was working
with jeep so it was in violation but
they said that i was using it and i
didn't take it down in time so they
banned my account for a year i'm still
actually blocked you can't i couldn't
search for my account you couldn't like
my account i couldn't share my account
and every single person that liked my
account seemed to be shadow band you
know it sucks when don jr likes your
page and that's a detriment right
because if there's these bad blue check
marks out there and everyone thinks oh
it's a blue check mark that's just a
famous person well look behind the back
end you know they're classifying and
category categorizing your blue
checkbook if you're a celebrity that has
positive messages in their opinion you
get exposure if you're a celebrity a
politician that has a message that goes
against their narrative then you are
banned not necessarily officially if
they can't do it but you'll be shadow
banned and everyone sees it yeah and and
it's known but we have no transparency
there's no oversight and these social
media oligarchs they've been acting
as such they're untouchable they can do
whatever and it's it's uh despicable i
think i think your company is a really
good example of the censorship that's
overlooked these high profile left and
establishment journalists will be like
oh when when when joe rogan got canceled
it made him bigger or whatever and and
that's what they want people to think
canceling is meanwhile your business
gets shut down and there's no big
fanfare there's no big headline
most of the people i hear from who say
they got banned are like small accounts
oh yeah no and we're talking about
millions of followers and we're talking
about
um millions of dollars for a relatively
small business right i started my garage
and and now we have large accounts i
have bass pro i have cabela's i have
five six retail stores that are very you
know highly frequented in charleston and
savannah and del rey and people come
from all over to our store to experience
it and that that gives us a a sense of
you know you could try to shut me down
but i'm not going away i'll find a new
platform and i was really excited about
twitter being that new platform because
i i don't even have an account you asked
me earlier what's my twitter account i
don't think i have one um because i'm
kind of over social you know if i could
pull all of my marketing dollars i would
um right now they don't seem to care if
i'm spending well over a million dollars
a year with facebook and they cancel my
account rep because of a false narrative
just because you don't like my opinions
and of all of the groups that are like
me i'm probably the least noisy the
least
in your face but i i do appreciate the
second amendment the first amendment and
i got banned from writing
the
first amendment on a t-shirt and it was
told to me that that was against
facebook's policies and we're like yeah
first amendment you know the rights that
shall not
can't have people learning about that
but i pushed out an email to our one
million plus you know active email
accounts and we will sell a ton of
shirts and i will get a way around it
it's just very sad that i can't promote
first amendment second amendments you
take those away and there's no stopping
a government i had an idea for a tv show
we talked about once i think it was like
on the members podcast where it's this
post-apocalyptic future
and there's like one city left
and uh no one understands how the world
ended but like the world ended and then
like people came together and built a
city and they're rebuilding and it's
like sometime around 2077 or you know
2080 or whatever just history just dead
stops and then humanity's just gone from
the planet cities are in ruin and decay
and then the idea for this was
you know the people in the city
eventually encounter strange beings i
think are aliens they go to war then it
turns out oh the aliens are actually
people and the world didn't end what
happened was as techno technology
advanced more and more information went
into the metaverse then eventually
people just went into the metaverse and
they live their lives there now and
there's very little work that has to be
done because they're not really moving
their bodies they don't need that much
caloric energy and so there's only
certain scouts that go out to replenish
the system i i we talked about that and
i got that idea because you know i was
thinking of how social media works how
these how these like social networks are
banning people
and then uh just just the this past
weekend i was at an antique store and we
were looking at all these books
this guy had a bunch of crazy we had
books from the civil war we got the
photographic collection uh photographic
history of the civil war crazy from
1911. so there's actual photos of like
the 1860s it's it's nuts
that's not going to exist in the future
the way it's going with social media and
why it's so important that someone like
you know elon pushed back i don't think
he cares anymore i don't i think he's
trying to get away from the whole thing
but the reason why social media
censorship is so dangerous
if the world ended right now
the overwhelming majority of information
would be gone like world ending i mean
if let's say the power went out in every
major city
you would not be able to access our
website timcast.com i mean the
information exists on the hardware some
somewhere where's the data center who
knows how you're going to look up the ip
just i don't know computers shut down so
if
you know 100 years ago there's a
collapse
society breaks down you walk into a
library you find all the books still
sitting there hopefully not damaged but
these books could be all over the place
you could find the history and be like
wow look at this
in the future it's going to be very
different if there is a major collapse
catastrophe
like that overnight
no one is going to know where any of
this information is and if you don't
have electricity or a means to decode
the the data off the hard drives
you know there could be a solar flare or
a great war and let's say it's a hundred
year 150 years and people are like
looking at these mainframes going the
summation of human knowledge exists on
these machines it could teach us so much
about the world and how to survive but
we can't get access to it because we
lost that technology when the collapse
happened no books no reading nothing you
can preserve maybe you'll get lucky and
someone will figure it out anyway i
bring that up because like
the way it's going with censorship
that idea i had for a show it's like the
reason there was a last city because
those are the people who weren't allowed
in these are these are the descendants
of the people who were banned from the
metaverse and had to go and build their
own economy somewhere else
so what i see happening with censorship
you're going to have people who get
banned and they will find a way to
engage in commerce
my dystopian future vision of it is
a city of people living you know because
their descendants are forced to work and
live in this alternate space and then
everyone else lives in the virtual
reality but i kind of think that's a
that's one direction we're going in
maybe it won't be that bad
the reality of these things is these
predictions typically don't pan out
because within 20 years technology will
have changed so much my prediction will
make no sense
but there you go well have you ever seen
the movie idiocracy yes it's one of my
favorite actually kind of starts to
prove that fact that you have uh
smartphones and dumb people
and we're not making or doing a service
to our young people or to the
individuals who just like that that easy
button we're making it easier and easier
and easier for society and we're telling
them that when you
fail it's not your fault when you fail
it you need to blame everything
elsewhere you know that that idea of
ownership that idea of you know wanting
to go and read through an encyclopedia
to find an answer but if i can't find it
on the first page of google you know
that's what sometimes i'll talk to my
younger employees like hey sir you told
me to go and research something so i
went on google and i searched and
nothing came up like wow
and then you came directly back to me
that's very sad and but it's it's
exactly what you probably have seen a
lot in the
say younger generation i i grew up with
no phone than a flip phone and now i
have a phone but i despise it if i can
get away from this thing and i can get
back into reading books and engaging in
conversation because that's where real
knowledge comes from that's what's it's
debate you know it's not reading what
someone else posted on google right that
wikipedia where anyone can alter it and
people come to me with these facts about
masks about
vaccines it's funny how when things
become mainstream everyone all of a
sudden becomes a subject matter expert
like that because on the front page of
google might do 100 yeah everything got
shut down uh for covered right i became
a non-essential company so my company
with 250 people was forced to
shut down and die that's closing company
yeah
not clothes are essential right and i
had black ripple coffee was my favorite
coffee free coffee at all first
responders but uh you know our coffee
shops were shut down our uh retail
stores were shut down our manufacturing
plant
what state
georgia wow really yeah yeah and there
was definitely some internal politics
going on there that you know it caused
that but uh
i'd say that if i didn't switch and to
start distributing these cloth masks
that i knew were not effective in any
way shape or form you know i'm an
engineer i like making and building
things we made our own n95 masks you
know ones that actually worked uh that
were made here in the united states but
there's no way we were getting any type
of large contracts you know they were
going to 3m they're going to honeywell
so that they could take these billion
dollar contracts by the way they still
haven't produced these masks you know
500 plus million mass that you know were
given billion dollar contracts they
didn't have to be produced for 18 months
you know i bid on them and said that i
could do it with my partners at
gulfstream my partners that were these
nasa-based engineering firms that had
proven that our science worked and that
it was cheaper better faster made in the
us but no one wanted to hear it and
that's where you know that that science
is overruled by political science you
know the math and the numbers in the
engineering is no longer a discussion so
i could go on television and and talk
about
things based on my knowledge of science
and engineering and be challenged by
some youtube
dummy who just googled fauci's last
periodical of nonsense and and said you
know what you're wrong and you're
against the science and you just want to
promote all these negative things and
therefore you are a bad human and and
you can't even engage in conversation
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you